[Musik]
kurze Frage heizen sie schon
sicher
würden sie ja schwören schwören sie
nicht im Moment schwören sie auf das
Leben von Gerhard Schröder ja ich
schwöre ich auf das Leben schon auf das
Leben ich heize
er heizen sie schon
heizen sie schon weil sie haben die Tür
nach auf das wäre gut dann um Energie zu
sparen die Tür zu machen haben sie
dieses Jahr die Heizung schon mal
angemacht nein ich heize mit Kerzen wenn
sie im Supermarkt gehen es gibt keine
Katzen mehr weil sie alle aufgekauft
haben nicht durch wie groß sind die
können Sie mal zeigen
so eine so eine Flamme hat 1400 Grad ich
gebe es zu im Badezimmer und im
Wohnzimmer haben ein Heizkörper ich
glaube von 10 Heizkörpern haben wir zwei
an muss das sein ja mir ist kalt es wird
ja kalt haben sie die Heizung schon an
ja
Schande Schande Schande Schande Schande
Schande aber wir hatten nur noch 14 Grad
im Haus ja trotzdem als wir aus dem
Urlaub zurückkam ach im Urlaub waren sie
auch noch sind ja immer schöner wo waren
Sie denn im Sauerland das ist ja kein
Urlaub heizen sie eigentlich schon nein
und das ist kein elektrisches Rad ne gut
heizen sie schon ja natürlich
das finden sie in Ordnung ja natürlich
wenn man das ganze System versteht
wie ist denn das System
Google ja das ist eine gute Idee googeln
ja wieso googeln wir denn eigentlich
nicht ich wollte mal fragen ob sie schon
heizen ja
eine Woche okay okay
kann ich mir das mal anschauen bei Ihnen
das Heizen ja
das ist jetzt zum Beispiel eine Heizung
ist die jetzt an oder ist die nicht
anders kann dies an kann man die auch
komplett ausschalten das ist schon
könnten wollen sie das nicht machen nein
hier ist es natürlich kann ich gerade
man muss gerade mal messen jetzt würde
ich abschließend noch mal ihre
Körpertemperatur messen
[Musik]
was haben Sie denn heute mit mir vor
Ründchen schwimmen ins Wasser ist nicht
so kalt es ist 13 14 Grad gibt es
irgendwelche Tricks wie man das aushält
ja indem man akzeptiert und atmet kommt
Hüften
aber so wäre doch jetzt auch schon mal
könnte man auch sagen ich habe es
geschafft oder ich war am See
machen noch ein kleines Stückchen Lutz
ich tue es auch für die heute-show ich
tue es für die heute schon weil wir
moralisch überlegen sind wir sind das
Format das oder anderen zeigt dass wir
nicht nur reden können sondern wir
machen es auch wir gehen in das Wasser
rein und wegen der Energiekrise ja das
meine ich ja damit okay gut
[Applaus]
gestern Klamotten brauche ich nicht
[Musik]
hallo Youtube unten könnt ihr den Kanal
abonnieren er deutet nach unten in die
Infobox neben mir gibt es weitere
interessante Videos Verlinkungen Komma
vielen Dank
[Musik]